so we talked about
two uh different forms of propulsion
which are super exciting so the chemical
based
that's doing pretty well and then the
electric base is
um are there types of propulsion
that might sound like science fiction
right now but are actually within the
reach of science in the next
10 20 30 50 years that you kind of think
about
or maybe even within the space of even
just like
like even ion engines is there like
breakthroughs that might 10x the thing
like really improve it so you know the
real
game changer would be propellant-less
propulsion and so every couple years you
see a new
now a startup or a researcher
comes up with some contraption for
producing thrust that didn't require
you know we've been talking about
conservation of momentum mass times
velocity
out the back um there's usually forward
yes
exactly and you have to
you know carry that up with you or find
it on an asteroid or harvest
it from somewhere if you didn't bring it
with you so not having to do that would
be
you know one of the ultimate game
changers
and and i you know unless there are
new types of physics um i don't know
how we do it but it comes up often so
it's something i i do think about and
um you know the one i think it's called
the casmir effect
um if you can if you have two plates and
and the space between them is on the
order of these like
the wavelength of these ephemeral vacuum
particles that pop into and out of
existence or something
um i may be confusing multiple types of
propellant-less
forces but um that
that could be real and could be
something that
that we use eventually what would be the
power source
yeah the most recent engine like this
that
has was just debunked this year
i think in in march or something was
called the m drive and
um supposedly you you used a power
source so
you know batteries or solar panels to
generate microwaves into this resident
cavity
and people claimed it produced thrust so
they
they went straight from this really
loose concept to building a device and
testing it and they said
we've measured thrust and sure on their
thrust balance they saw thrust and
different researchers built it and
tested it and got the same measurements
and so it was looking actually pretty
good
no one could explain how it worked but
what they said was that
this inside the cavity um the microwaves
themselves
didn't change but the speed of light
changed inside the cavity so relative to
that
um you know their momentum was conserved
um and i don't you know i
whatever um but finally someone i think
at nasa built the device
tested it got the same thrust then
unhooked it flipped it backwards and
turned it on but got the same thrust
in the same direction again and so
they're like this is just an interaction
with the test
set up or you know some of the chamber
or something like that
so um forwarded again um but
you know it would be so wonderful for
everybody if we could figure out how to
do it but i don't know
you